magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman i want to
start today uh as we have many days in
the last week and talk about the russian
invasion of ukraine but i want to zoom
out a little bit and take a little bit
more of like a systemic big picture 30
000 foot view you know one of the goals
of vladimir putin and russia
uh for
more than a decade now in earnest and
you could argue really even longer than
that is to weaken what's seen as the
west uh the united states and europe or
you know you could sort of characterize
it uh in in a number of different ways
weaken the west
make the united states and western
democracy look
weaker or in question or untrustworthy
in some way
and the general goal of this is to make
russia look better in comparison i mean
this is a very
basic and sort of crude way to say it
but when you think about the three major
superpowers the united states russia and
china
the worse any one of them looks
the better by comparison others look and
so when we think back to the trump era
and we wonder or or
we don't really have to wonder but we
think about
why putin would want and benefited from
trump rather than hillary clinton being
president and chaos electorally and
claims about voter fraud and all these
things why does putin benefit from that
well when you step back and look at the
three major powers
if the u.s looks silly
if the u.s looks stupid if the u.s looks
so ignorant that there are enough people
that they would vote for a clown like
trump
by comparison it makes russia look
better
and
one of the
main goals of putin in general is to
make
the the west and the us look worse and
the most
the more fragmented that the west is
uh the weaker that it appears to be and
unfortunately
for putin
his invasion of ukraine
has sort of accidentally or as a side
effect unified and strengthened the west
to the extent that the west is now
very clear with some exceptions you know
you turn on fox news you'll see
pro putin apologia but for the most part
putin's invasion of ukraine has actually
had the unintended consequence of
unifying and strengthening the west
there's an interesting article that you
can check out uh by holly elliot on cnbc
called putin's always wanted to weaken
the west he's done the exact opposite
and the article actually explains if
there's anything we've learned about
putin over the 22 years he's been in
power
it's that he has systematically and
repeatedly tried to weaken and undermine
the west but in his invasion of ukraine
he seems to have achieved the exact
opposite managing to unite most of the
international community in its
condemnation of russia's aggression
towards its neighbor
ian bremmer president of political risk
consultancy eurasia group commented
quote nato is united more so than at any
point since the soviet collapse with a
renewed sense of purpose and mission so
too is the european union germany
supports ending their economic
dependence on russia and is nearly
doubling their defense spend france is
on board even moscow tilting hungary has
condemned the invasion favored a
crippling sanctions regime and is
allowing in hundreds of thousands of
ukrainian refugees refugees the west is
used to russia behaving like a malign
actor
um
over time it's also widely seen as
responsible for uh rather uh it also
sees russia as responsible for a nerve
agent attack on uk soil in 2018 and was
subsequently sanctioned and it goes on
to explain that this may have been in a
sense
the worst unintended consequence of what
putin is doing now putin may end up dead
at the end of this entire thing we don't
know putin may end up deposed out of
power
we don't know putin may end up taking
ukraine
we we don't know at this point in time
but
the way in which this has unified the
west over the long term is not
particularly good for putin's bigger
picture ambitions now there's another
aspect to this which we've seen at the
david pakman show and i've talked to
some other independent media people and
everybody's seeing the same thing over
the last 10 to 14 days
there has been a notable decline
in a certain strain
of bot type right wing trolling
all over our platforms i'm talking
youtube twitter reddit etc
there has been for the last many years
um a suspicious amount of comments like
i'm as liberal as the next guy but
and then they use some like right wing
argument to try to make it seem as
though even left wingers
are skeptical of the american left and
all this different stuff you know stuff
like um uh listen
uh i i'm i'm a foreigner
and i just don't understand why is
having a needing a photo id such a bad
thing for voting you need an id for
everything else all these repetitive
sorts of messages that we see posted on
all of our platforms
they have diminished dramatically in the
last 10 to 14 days now i don't think
it's because they are all
russian trolls
but we know that russia
for a long time
has waged pretty slick
uh sort of disinformation type campaigns
online all over the world and shows like
ours have absolutely uh been affected by
them if you look at any of our platforms
that is down dramatically it seems
because they are uh
at least to some degree
uh preoccupied
with trying to justify this invasion of
ukraine and uh the next months
presumably
will give us a sense of is russia
heading towards annexing ukraine or
installing a puppet government is russia
heading in the opposite direction of
going in the direction of a truly failed
state for a long time with a broken
economy that remains to be seen but
putin succeeded at calling into question
american democracy when trump won and
then when they fomented the big lie
ideas that trump won again in 2020 even
though he didn't he he succeeded at that
he really did
but without a doubt
to some degree
the biggest unintended unintended
consequence of the russian invasion of
ukraine is that much of the west is now
as united as it has been in a really
really long time putin may end up taking
ukraine we just don't know yet and i
think anybody who
leans on the inevitability of one
outcome or the other there's people who
are saying listen sooner or later
putin's going to get ukraine
i don't think that that's uh something
we can accurately say
on the other hand you have the
perspective that sooner or later
russia's going to get just absolutely
crushed here and putin will be removed
killed whatever i don't think that
that's a foregone conclusion either i
don't think we know the answer
but
when you see the west as united as it is
it doesn't bode particularly well for
russia
one other russia ukraine story i want to
mention this made big headlines over the
last 24 hours and the headline is
russian airstrike has hit
a ukrainian
maternity hospital the associated press
is reporting
a russian airstrike devastated a
maternity hospital wednesday in the
besieged port city of mariopol
amid growing warnings from the west that
moscow's invasion is about to take a
more brutal and indiscriminate turn
ukrainian officials said the attack
wounded at least 17 people the ground
shook more than a mile away when the
mario paul complex was hit by a series
of blasts that blew out windows and
ripped away much of the front of one
building
vladimir nikulin a top regional police
official standing in the ruins said
today russia committed a huge crime it
is a war crime without any justification
this story alone is generating a ton of
discussion about what what is the truth
here on the one hand there was the
reaction that russia is now deliberately
bombing
uh maternity hospitals and we saw the
hit the airstrike against an orphanage
last week uh and against the children's
hospital last week so one perspective is
they're doing this on purpose to wreak
havoc and cause terror the counterpoint
was it is of no advantage whatsoever to
putin to deliberately strike a maternity
hospital what would be the point
obviously russia doesn't think that
pregnant mothers and health care workers
and newborn babies are the ones waging
the war against them so they would never
deliberately hit
a maternity hospital if they did it must
be indifference or lack of precision
however the the latest that i've read is
russia is claiming that the maternity
ward
was being used as a stage as a staging
area
for
ukrainian troops and volunteers etc and
that there were not actually any
pregnant women in the maternity ward at
the time and that when ukraine says our
maternity ward was hit that it's merely
propaganda because everybody knows that
it's actually a military staging area do
we ultimately know the truth uh maybe
maybe i i certainly don't know it right
now and i'm open to it being any of the
above that i just mentioned but i think
the most important takeaway from
individual stories like this
uh are that it is complete and total
chaos
and
that this is still
an optional invasion by russia and so
it's very easy you know i look at these
discussions that happen online and
people are getting extraordinarily
flustered and angry with each other and
adversarial over no no this was
obviously deliberate
no no no obviously russia would never
deliberately hit a maternity ward it
goes against their strategic objectives
and it goes against their pr objectives
as well
i don't think we know and one of the
things that we are seeing is when folks
get involved in the minutia and i'm not
saying we don't care whether a maternity
ward was hit obviously we do and
obviously people are getting wounded and
people are dying and 17 wounded is
supposedly the number uh from this
particular incident when you get bogged
down in the details the point is
you end up fighting with people assuming
that they're good faith actors now if
they're just tr you know russian trolls
pro-russian trolls okay then then it's
that that's a different story but when
you get bogged down in the in the
specifics of what happened in this one
incident
it's very easy to lose the main thread
which is this is an optional
premeditated
invasion of aggression of ukraine
by russia
and when we end up arguing with people
about
would would russia deliberately do this
if they knew that there were not
actually ukrainian troops there or if
they did or
we end up missing that big picture and
that's the big picture that we have to
remember and and quite frankly going
back to the previous segment i did
that big picture of an optional
premeditated invasion of aggression by
russia to try to take land or to install
a puppet government whatever ultimately
is putin's goal
that's the big picture that has united
the west and american allies and nato
allies and so we want to know what
happened here we do and it matters what
happened here it doesn't change the big
picture of what's going on in the region
and i think that's the important
takeaway let me know your thoughts you
can find me on twitter at dpakman
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman one
of the popular talking points that's
developed among the right-wing media
including fox news recently is that joe
biden is making gas prices higher by not
restarting construction of the keystone
xl pipeline and built into this entire
story are misunderstandings about what
the keystone xl pipeline is and what it
would do how long it would take to
construct it as well as the degree to
which presidents impact gas prices
particularly when the va the price of
oil is soaring globally
and and all of these things are being
missed with really kind of um uh it's
not even really pedantic they're they're
just
confused talking points from right
wingers one example that we're going to
look at right now is peter ducey from
fox news
for days ducey has been hammering
joe biden's white house press secretary
jen saki about gas prices and the
keystone xl pipeline and he seems to
understand very little about it not
surprisingly so let's look at his first
attempt from yesterday or his latest
attempt i guess we would call it from a
press briefing yesterday on this talking
point and then i'm going to tell you a
little bit about the truth about
keystone xl because there's a lot of
gray area here it is a restart of the
keystone xl construction completely off
the table as long as joe biden is
president well why don't you tell me
what that would help address
i'm asking you if it is an option you
guys say all options are on the table is
restarting keystone construction one of
them if we're trying to bring about more
supply that does not address any problem
it's supply from canada a friendly ally
instead of saudi arabia that's already
that's we're already getting that oil
peter it's the the pipeline is just a
delivery mechanism it is not an oil
field so it does not provide more supply
into the system it does not address
stable is it possible that joe biden
will ever
say
you guys can go ahead with construction
of keystone xl there's no plans for that
and it would not address any of the
problems we're having currently okay so
all of these right wingers talking about
keystone xl keystone xl first of all as
jen saki points out it's merely a
pipeline it's not a source of oil and
canadian oil is already coming into the
united states the pipeline in camp and
and here's the most important thing now
yesterday on my stream i asked people in
my in the audience do you guys realize
that phases one two and three of the
keystone xl pipeline are already up and
running when they talk about keystone xl
and when they talk about oh biden
stopped it and trump tried to do it and
obama stopped it do you guys realize
that it's just phase four of keystone xl
95
of my audience didn't know that
and that's by design when the right says
they've stopped keystone xl we're
getting no oil
phases one two and three of the keystone
xl pipeline are and have been up and
running it runs i believe from canada
from alberta to illinois and texas and
oklahoma these pipelines are already in
place what's at issue when people say
biden stopped it is biden stopped
construction of phase four and
there's controversy around phase four
because of how it would go through
indigenous land and the the indigenous
uh communities that would be affected
uh have not really been uh players at
the table in a way that many of us in
the united states think they should be
so obama delayed it and then trump tried
to resume that construction and then
biden stopped it and ultimately tc
energy the company in place has
abandoned it so first and foremost
keystone xl is up and running phase one
is up and running phase two is up and
running phase three is up and running
number two
uh it is not a method of supply it is a
method of transport
and number three
it would take probably years to complete
if you started that construction right
now and it would be a very modest amount
of oil relative to the total u.s need
it's a silly bogus talking point even if
biden said let's do phase four
it would not solve the problem right now
in any way
um do see continuing to just use these
confused different talking points here
trying to do a gotcha around
calling the gas price increases the
putin price hikes did you guys decide to
re-brand the rise and gas prices as the
hashtag putin price hike
i mean if you want to use that on fox i
welcome that but i think it'll get a lot
of air time because we have heard the
president warn for months the gas prices
were rising because of the supply chain
and because of post-pandemic demand if
you guys knew for months that this was
going to be the hashtag putin price hike
why are we just hearing that now
so of course i mean gensake's answer
doesn't even matter again
uh gas prices can go up at different
times for different reasons and the what
when remember when gas prices started
going up at the end of trump's
presidency
and they continued going up when joe
biden took over it was a global
phenomenon as a result of the resumption
and demand with the easing of the
pandemic we now are seeing gas prices go
up more
and it has to do with expectations
remember oil prices are sort of a
futures market it we are now seeing it
happen as a result of what's going on in
russia ukraine and for supply reasons
etc
all of these things can be true it's
sort of like if i wake up one day and i
have a headache because i didn't sleep
well
and then that night i bump my head and
the next day i have an even worse
headache it'd be like well why did you
why did you say it was because you were
tired on day one because you actually
bumped your head right on day one the
headache was because i was tired on day
two it was because i bummed my head
different causes can have a similar
effect one more example of the confusion
around this keystone xl thing here is
former obama economic advisor robert
wolf on fox news and he says this
keystone xl thing would not actually fix
the problem we're dealing with right now
and the fox anchor says well that's
debatable he's like no it's not all
right so if that's not going to happen
robert perhaps as peter just reported
perhaps
opening up the keystone pipeline is not
off the table for this white house what
did you take away from that
i think excel is off the table let's
recall a few things one it's the worst
type of oil you can have it's tar sands
going from alberta to the gulf of mexico
it wasn't going to really change
anything to do with our oil supply it
was to export from the gulf of mexico
also recall that under president
okay it's not actually debatable um
uh it has nothing to do with oil fields
it's a pipeline it was going to end at
the gulf of mexico that's a fact you
should look it up yeah um this is the
problem you know how i've been saying to
you guys one of the problems we have
right now in american sort of in the
media milieu and in society in general
is people don't agree about what are
facts now
the the wording i'm using is very
important i'm not saying people don't
agree about what the facts are that
would be like i think you know i don't
know what the fact i think inflation's
gone up and you think it's gone down
okay whatever like that would be a
disagreement about the facts people
don't agree about what types of
statements are statements of fact the
keystone xl pipeline
is
something in particular it's not open to
opinion what the keystone xl pipeline is
or where it would have been or how much
oil it would have transported or whether
it's a source of oil or just a transport
method those are not opinions
those are things we can definitively
know
and the problem is when the fox news
anchor says well that's debatable
it's really not i mean you you can make
an argument that it's something else you
would be wrong it's not a statement of
opinion these are statements of fact and
just look at previous reporting about
the pipeline from when obama was
president um and uh there are actually
reports from back then that say
phase four of keystone xl could actually
cause a gas price increase in the
midwest in particular because the oil
would be transported through there but
it's not intended for american consumers
the the reporting is out there so they
don't know as usual what the hell
they're talking about
i want to look with you at some
record-setting clips of a new donald
trump interview donald trump was
interviewed and to call it an interview
is kind of weird because it was just a
fluff piece ronna mcdaniel the rnc chair
who i guess now has a podcast she
interviewed donald trump and donald
trump i'm going to play a clip for you
in which i believe in 12 seconds he
tells four lies it's it's record setting
quite literally um but just to give you
a sense of this bizarre interview here
is ronna mcdaniel
talking about how great trump has been
to women i i know guys i know thank you
for what you're doing thank you for
being out there i just have two fun
things i wanted to say to you this is
going to be fun guys we're about to have
fun and
you're such a wonderful person you've
been so great to women thank you for
what you're doing
um
trump's been accused of harassment
through assault
of 46 women by 46 women
um and she says you you've just been so
fantastic for women now here's the clip
this is a 17 second clip
ronna mcdaniel speaks for five seconds
so trump only speaks for 12 seconds and
he tells four lies
see if you can spot him okay here's it
it'll be like a game show dur and you
saved hundreds of thousands if not
millions of lives with that well you
know we had in 1917
100 million people died i think we would
have had the same thing so we did
something that was incredible we did it
in less than nine months and it was
supposed to take anywhere from five to
12 years
so did you spot the four lies or
misstatements there
first it's it he only spoke 12 seconds
more like 11 but the math is easier if
we say 12. um he said that there was a
pandemic in 1917 there wasn't it was in
1918. he keeps telling that lie we don't
know why he's sticking with it uh number
two he says that if it weren't for the
vaccines he developed 100 million people
would have died of covid there is no
serious estimate that suggests that
number three he says he's the one who
got the vaccines done that's also untrue
all he did was agree to pre-purchase
some vaccines which any american
president would have done in this
situation and number four
he says it it were not for him it would
have taken five to 12 years to develop
the vaccine that's not true
with the vaccine that you build from
scratch
that was historically the case
mrna technology has been in development
for decades and the whole point of mrna
technology is you can much more quickly
sequence a virus and develop a vaccine
in about a year which is exactly what
happened
four lies
in 12 seconds
unbelievable couple other clips from
this interview here is trump saying
stopping nordstream was the worst thing
to ever happen to russia
history buffs will know that's not true
there was never anybody tougher on
russia than i was now that's a lie also
and i would say that putin would if he
was being honest he would say that
the sanctions i put on i was the one
that ended nordstrom exactly there was
never anybody even close i mean
nordstrom to them nordstrom 2 was the
biggest thing nobody ever even heard of
it until i came along complained and
then i shut it down
and there was never anything so big that
happened to russia shutting down
nordstrom 2 and then now russia
you know the soviet union
lost 27 million people during world war
ii
and then when the ussr collapsed one of
the uh
just absolute and total economic
disaster i i think it's a bit
exaggerated to say nordstream 2 was the
worst and biggest thing that happened
there and then lastly trump uh says the
following about how president xi
reacted to biden pulling out of
afghanistan
i think that's actually a big reason why
the problem you have with ukraine i
think when putin and washi and when kim
jong-un and when the iranians are
watching that the iranian leaders
i think they saw what happened in
afghanistan and i think that gave them
a new sense of power and dignity
[Laughter]
what is he even it's a word salad it's a
word salad she got a sense of dignity
from biden leaving afghanistan it's out
of this world guys it's completely and
totally meaningless but notably
four lies
in 12 seconds in that earlier clip
that's one lie every three three seconds
that actually
i would have if you said david you have
12 seconds to tell four lies
you need real uh linguistic efficiency
to even make that happen and trump does
it without even thinking about it we'll
have these clips on our instagram find
them at david pakman show we'll take a
quick break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome tom hartman back
to the program tom hosts the thom
hartmann program and is also author of
the hidden history series the latest
book in the series is the hidden history
of big brother in america how the death
of privacy and the rise of surveillance
threaten us and our democracy tom always
great speaking to you
hey david great to be here with you
thank you for inviting me so um
james gleick wrote this book the
information and one of the things that
glike writes in the book is that for as
long as there has been any communication
technology think
drums to communicate over long distances
in the african savannah there has also
been the ability to surveil
intercept
send confusing messages to trick those
wishing to communicate in that in that
method and you can sort of follow that
with every communications technology up
through today
when and how would you say that what we
might consider
the modern kind of surveillance and lack
of privacy apparatus really got going in
the united
states it was in the late 90s um
prior to 1996
the internet operated under the same uh
telecommunications rules as telephone
companies when this went back to the
nineteen thirties uh it to this day if
you're on a phone call with somebody and
it's actually being carried over cell
towers it's not a voip call it's not a
voiceover internet call um because the
rules for the internet are now different
but if you're talking to somebody on a
cell tower or on a regular phone
uh for the phone company to listen in
for the government to listen in for any
third party to listen in they have to
have a warrant there has to be a legal
basis for that intrusion
in nineteen ninety six with the
telecommunications act section two
thirty
um said we're going to drop that for the
internet
so uh that that's one piece of it the
other is uh or another metaphor that to
kind of explain where we're at
is that prior to 1996 the rules for
uh people who host sites on the internet
were very similar to the rules for
people who uh own
uh disco clubs you know dance venues
bars restaurants or you're in your home
i mean if you david were to put a sign
out in front of your house that said hey
big party on saturday come on in and
just leave the front door open and
you're sitting in your living room
saturday afternoon the sun's going down
there's there's somebody raping a woman
in the back room there's a there's a
bunch of people shooting up heroin over
in the corner uh there's a guy in the
other back room who's who's selling uh
illegal pornography and the police bust
in
they would not only arrest all those
people they would arrest you as the host
of the party right you have a
responsibility for what happens in your
house that you know about
and that was you know i mean this goes
back to british common law back to
literally the 10th century
so section 230 of the telecommunications
act of 1996
said that's still true for your house
it's still true for a bar it's still
true for a restaurant it's still true
for a civic center but it's not true for
anybody who builds a house on the
internet
and thus
mark zuckerberg became one of the
wealthiest men in the world uh he built
a house and he said hey come on in and
have a party and he largely ignored the
people who were shooting heroin in the
corner and selling you know i mean they
started they eventually started cracking
down
obviously they were from the beginning
and on the obvious stuff but even now
there's just i mean you know this new
report that january 6 was largely
planned on facebook and this isn't just
a trash facebook i'm i'm not you know
he's playing by the rules and that's the
problem i mean you know
in when you have capitalism in a
republic
the job of government is to set the
rules so that capitalism can work in a
way that doesn't damage society
and
uh we have failed in that regard
so the
republicans during the trump era talked
a lot about section 230 and some of them
seemed to think
that if the platforms uh um had greater
liability
for the content that was posted that it
would benefit the right in some way i
guess because they believed that the
left is regularly defaming and
slandering and so on and so forth but
they they seem to sort of misunderstand
the the true impact that changing
section 230 would would have do they not
yeah i mean i think the rights embrace
of changes in section 230 came along
with donald trump complaining about how
he was being treated by social media
right um they thought somehow if they
repealed that part of section 230 uh
that you know a thousand flowers would
bloom or something i don't know you know
i've never seen the logic in it um josh
hawley actually wrote one of the better
books about the horrors of section 230.
um the last half of the book is
basically
mostly a screed about how liberals want
to destroy america but you know the
first part of his book is a really good
description of the problems and what's
going on and why
um and and you know you've got people
like ron wyden you know the my senator
here in in oregon as one of the leaders
of the effort to change section 230 but
it is bipartisan josh hawley's on board
too
um so you know back
in 1980 or 81 i started running forms
for compuserve nigel peacock who's still
my webmaster and i he he lives in the uk
we were running forums we had like 30 of
them you know the ibm pc forum the
macintosh forum the jfk assassination
forum the ufo forum uh the adhd forum we
had a whole bunch of them and uh
compuserve paid us well i mean i we had
a staff we had about 30 people volunteer
they weren't volunteers we we paid them
who were working with us
and it was a it was a fair amount of
money that copy server was paying us
because this was before section 230 and
they built this house it was called this
is before html this is before the web as
we know it today
and copy serve and aol were pretty much
the only game in town
and so because they had built a house on
the internet they had responsibility for
what happened in that house and so we
were the ones who were kind of the hall
monitors
and in nineteen ninety six when section
two thirty past uh basically they laid
us all off
uh that was
where they stopped paying us right
you could keep working but we're no
longer going to yeah um you know that
there's progressive conservative and
libertarian
perspectives uh in terms of opposition
to the sort of surveillance that that we
now know takes place but they're they're
sort of different principles it's sort
of like with flat earth you talk to four
flat earthers they all believe the earth
is flat but for conflicting and
sometimes very very different reasons
and progressives conservatives and
libertarians have different reasons for
opposing the the practices that we see
now can you talk a little bit about
those different perspectives
uh with regard to section 230 or just
more generally more generally
cn things well i you know i think to the
extent that and and we're seeing this in
particular with the with
republicans across the country
tightening the screws on your right to
vote
that
uh the
the
for lack of a better phrase the police
state aspect
of because in my book i i basically
break out two kinds of big brother
there's the state big brother which is
what george orwell wrote about and then
there's the corporate big brother which
george orwell hadn't anticipated and and
which is actually at the moment far more
aggressive or at least you know the the
tip of the iceberg above i mean ed
snowden kind of showed us uh what
government was up to but
um
so anyway
the right seems to be embracing kind of
the police state tactics with regard to
voting
and and would be or generally are more
inclined to um
uh to to
not so much embrace police state tactics
on the internet but to say that
um you know if if the billionaires who
are running big social media sites
want to do what they want to do they
should be allowed to do it there's just
this reflexive thing against regulation
um
libertarians pretty much the same thing
i mean libertarians the this
the libertarian party was a scam it was
created in the 1940s by the real estate
lobby as a way to provide a a political
cover
for basically deregulation of the
industry
and uh you know they they thought of it
as as uh as a scam themselves i think it
still is to a large extent
um
you know the idea that a country can
work with nothing but the military and
the police being provided by the
government and the courts
um but uh i i think most democrats are
slowly
uh beginning to realize or understanding
um
my party metaphor really i mean this is
this is really what it is is that
um
you have to have rules for the game you
know the nfl defines the rules for
football
and if the nfl went all libertarian um
you know they they or all republican as
it were you know they could say they
would probably change their rules to say
well you know whichever team gives the
biggest contribution to the guys on our
board of directors gets an extra player
on the field throughout the game um you
know we can we can tweak things if
there's enough money involved and that
kind of thing um
that's
sadly and and that's what they've done i
mean there you go rick scott's new
11-point plan promoting deregulation of
the of the polluters right because
they're big campaign donors to the
republican party
so um with regard to privacy in the
united states i i think the dynamic is
just very similar david
when it comes to um you know in europe
we've got the gdpr california passed the
consumer privacy act in 2018 so at least
people know what personal data is is
being collected about them are are those
types of laws
significant and impactful or do they
give people maybe some kind of false
sense that something is being done
they are significant they do have impact
they they uh this these are the those
laws are why when you visit websites
that want to do business in california
or in europe uh they will say will you
accept cookies right um it's it's like a
flag it's a way of saying well yeah
there is something going on here we are
sort of spying on you or keeping track
of you or you know or maybe it's just to
help your experience um and in some
cases it is actually
but in any case i i think that that's
that's something that we need to you
know really seriously look at is the in
particular the european rules and and
the one uh there's a whole chapter about
this in my book in europe that we
definitely do not have here is the right
to be forgotten
um this came out of a 2018 lawsuit
uh or maybe was 2008
no
i'm sorry i'd have to look up the year
but you know uh there was a spanish guy
who discovered that whenever he googled
his name he had gone through a a rough
uh divorce and bankruptcy back in like
1998
and
uh lost his property lost his business
and when he googled his name he was he
had a real low profile guy and when he
googled his name that was pretty much
all that came up and it looked really
bad on him you know and it was impeding
his ability to to uh to get a date and
and and and find a job
and so he he asked google to delete that
from their search you know uh
things that came up when his name was
put in google kind of laughed at him um
he sued in spain and uh european court
went along with him and and now you've
got you know this this the right to be
forgotten across europe where if you
don't like
uh what is being said about you on the
internet uh you can't necessarily always
petition individual websites to take
down the content about you but you can
ask the search engines to no longer
deliver it to people
and that's a pretty consequential thing
and i know a lot of people in the united
states probably very much appreciate
that particularly people who have been
the victim of of uh you know uh
what's the phrase for when uh mostly men
are outing you know old girlfriends with
porn pictures and things like that oh
yeah uh what is the term for that i
don't remember the term yeah
yeah it's like revenge porn i think yeah
phrase
yeah um so
anyhow
that's something that we should
seriously look at as well
if uh last thing i want to touch on if
the direction that uh things have been
going isn't resisted in some of the ways
we've talked about and that you write in
the book
what what's sort of at the at the tail
end of it i mean is it the direction of
like the chinese social credit system
you know everybody has some different
idea of what they believe would be sort
of at the end of this what what do you
think would happen if this goes
unopposed
we already have a business version of
the chinese social credit system and
there are companies that brag that they
have ten fifteen twenty thousand data
points on every single one of us uh they
know our most subtle uh preferences they
know if we've you know for example if
they're providing information to a
company that's trying to decide whether
to answer your customer service call in
two rings or in two hours
uh you can tell that company if you have
recently browsed the website of that
company's competitors so are you one of
those people who's calling in and saying
hey i'd like that price match well you
get you get to wait two hours uh or if
you're a regular customer of that kind
you know just really really granular
data
and uh some of which could be used to
you know basically harass or embarrass
people as well as to increase the
profits of companies
so uh
and and and similarly there are
companies that specifically market you
know the this kind of social credit
score it's not just your finances it's
not just whether you paid your credit
card on time it's you know whether
you've ever been arrested for drunk
driving or whether you've ever been in
an altercation with anybody or you know
how you behaved online in some cases
they're selling this information to
employers they're selling this
information to landlords they're selling
this information to retail companies
they're selling this company to
companies you know just to cell phone
companies and airlines and everybody
else who get calls from customers
um
there's
the potential for uh abuse is
extraordinary and
i'm not saying that it's not appropriate
to do that you know if i was a landlord
i would like to know if the person who
wants to run an apartment to trash the
last one and let dog poop all over right
um you know that's not unreasonable
but uh
there there have to be reasonable limits
on this stuff and there are none right
now
the book is the hidden history of big
brother in america how the death of
privacy and the rise of surveillance
threaten us and our democracy the book's
author is tom hartman tom always
appreciate your time
thank you david it's always a great a
great honor and pleasure to hear be here
with you
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right well we have
uh very very big news another one of
these trumpest election clerk official
type people
has uh has been indicted i'm talking
here about tina peters we've spoken
about tina peters before
county clerk who embraced the big lie is
indicted months after an election data
leak this this really is a delightful
story um talking points memo reads tina
peters the republican clerk of mesa
county colorado who was long suspected
of aiding a leak of sensitive election
machinery data from her own office has
been indicted on multiple counts by a
colorado grand jury
as has her deputy belinda nisly or
knisley
according to the indictment peters and
knisley allegedly devised and executed a
scheme
to breach security protocols that led to
the distribution of confidential
information from county election systems
guys
the calls are coming from inside the
house to carry out the scheme the
indictment alleged peters committed
criminal impersonation against the
colorado man whose name was used for an
access badge for county election offices
the charges against peters this this is
just delightful the charges against
peters include three counts of
attempting to influence a public servant
one count of conspiracy to commit
attempt to influence a public servant
weird weird language but that i think
that's the way the law is written
criminal impersonation conspiracy to
commit criminal impersonation identity
theft first degree official misconduct
violation of duty and failing to comply
with the secretary of state
um
this
guy's this is what they say democrats do
to steal elections
there's another article from rs technica
republican county clerk indicted in
voting machine breach arrest warrant
issued tina peters indicted on 10 counts
for quote deceptive scheme to leak
confidential data this was long overdue
tina peters showed up you know those
pillow fests um mike mike lindell from
mypillow he was a big supporter of tina
peters
and this is way overdue
there is a clip which we previously
looked at on a live stream in which she
was arrested in public it's just so
delightful to see it and here are
officers taking her into custody she's
screaming
let go
and now she's starting to kick like a uh
like a threatened horse
give
so she was publicly taken into custody
it was just fantastic and by the way
she's running for secretary of state of
colorado and she had the audacity to put
out this video yesterday in the midst of
everything that's going on
hi i'm tina peters i'm currently the
clerk of mesa county and i've announced
that i'm running for the office of
secretary of state in colorado
since then i've been crisscrossing
colorado speaking to various civics
groups including republican lincoln day
dinners and i've been so honored by the
overwhelming response
i'm running for colorado's secretary of
state is it wrong that i take pleasure
in this horrible woman going down
um and you know i i'm not one to
celebrate bad things happening to people
but she's accused of doing not only
really bad things but she was part of
spreading the big lie that everybody on
the left was meddling with elections it
was democrats it was joe biden it was
whoever
she was involved in a conspiracy scheme
per the charges related to elections in
her role as the county clerk
i'm sorry guys i'm taking pleasure i'm
taking pleasure to restore trust
and put an end to your imagination
in our election process trust we need to
get back to honoring our colorado
constitution
honoring our state legislature to craft
laws through a representative government
by of and for the people yeah she's been
arrested she has now been arrested taken
into custody and it's all absolutely
fantastic law and order guys law and
order that's the important thing
speaking of law and order
radical
trumpist
republican congressman madison cawthorne
has been charged for driving with no
license
here's the key word
a second time
um north carolina congressman madison
cawthorne charged with driving with
revoked license for second time
he now has a court date
congressman madison cawthorne has been
charged with driving with a revoked
license a misdemeanor that carries up to
20 days in jail the 26 year old
republican was pulled over march 3rd in
cleveland county about an hour and a
half southeast of asheville by the
highway patrol along with the
misdemeanor kothorn is facing two
pending citations for speeding in
different counties highway patrol
spokesperson sergeant marcus bethea said
march 9 he could confirm that the three
citation numbers are pending matters the
cleveland county stop happened around
shelby
um trooper tyler gant
saw a 2019 toyota truck cross the center
line not you know pretty reckless
driving the driver was identified as
david madison cawthorne i guess is i
guess madison's his middle name uh
during the course of the investigation
it was determined the driver's license
was in a state of revocation he doesn't
have an actual valid license he was
charged with driving while license
revoked they claimed to be about law and
order and they're not
they claim that it's the left that's
doing all the election stuff but it's
actually them and in particular and this
is not a joke when it comes to motor
vehicle stuff you would think that
madison cawthorne would understand the
consequences of irresponsible driving
unlicensed driving all this stuff
he's in a wheelchair because of a car
accident he was involved in when he was
younger
in which if i recall correctly his
friend the driver
fell asleep and i'm not even going to
speculate on what that means
fell asleep can mean a lot of different
things when it comes to traffic
accidents
um and he is regularly speeding
crossing the center line
driving with no no valid license guys
come on it's it's the the double
standards and the hypocrisy i know they
don't care about them but at a certain
point it's almost like a skit they're
such hypocrites um no word as to whether
he pulled the do you know who i am sort
of game but this is a guy who regularly
you know to say he's deliberately
breaking the law we would need to know
his state of mind but he's at least at
minimum accidentally breaking it
remember when he tried to bring a gun on
a plane he had a gun in his carry-on and
he tried to bring it on a plane oh he
forgot where it was oh no it's just he's
a congressman sir responsible
congressman well if you forget where
your gun is
that doesn't sound like responsible gun
ownership one of the principles of
responsible gun ownership is you should
always know whether the gun is loaded
and you should always know where the gun
is
the gun was in his carry-on he didn't
believe or
he was not aware that it was in his
carry-on that's negligence but always oh
no these are just it's these are just
accidents
who's gonna who's he gonna blame for
this one antifa
uh black lives matter
critical race theory
joe biden socialism or maybe transgender
kids or george soros i don't know the
party of personal responsibility
very quick to say these were accidents
and certainly someone else is actually
to blame here so
second time second time caught driving
without a valid license
madison cothorn
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
now uh many of you will be familiar with
today's caller today's caller is the san
antonio troll the san antonio troll is
known to me and probably to some of you
for calling in
and delivering blistering criticism
directed at me
for things i never said
and that's exactly what he does today
typical of the san antonio troll
you know pac-man i watched your coverage
of the state of the union and
i just can't
i you progressives are the most
out-of-touch people
on the freaking planet okay and what's
funny is most of y'all are just pundits
you know
who live in nice neighborhoods gated
neighborhoods and
gated neighborhoods
you don't really see i thought biden did
a good job i think he's done a good job
so far that's fine that's that's totally
respectful okay and i think
his state of union was great
and i am absolutely prepared to vote for
a democrat
in 2024. i don't know if the san antonio
troll is serious about that but okay i
mean who's going because from ron de
santos come on where are we kidding here
having said all that
you complain about biden wanting to
bring energy production back to the
united states
whereas you don't see that it hurts the
working these gas prices hurt the
average person now this is where the
troll goes off the rails
i did not criticize joe biden wanting to
bring energy production domestically to
be honest i don't even know if joe biden
mentioned that
what i
spoke about was joe biden offhandedly
saying we're gonna build
and manufacture everything here in the
u.s and buy american and as i've said
before when donald trump has said things
like this as i said before when barack
obama said things like this
the kind of um
casual nature with which elected
officials say this ignores the reality
that our economy is based on not making
stuff here
we have decided
implicitly through our decisions about
trade and regulation over the last 20 to
30 years that we prefer as a country i'm
not saying you or i prefer it but we
prefer as a country to have lower prices
on stuff
and to make it abroad
and so when politicians they all do it
they say we're going to bring every
we're going to make everything here
it could take decades or longer to
reconstruct the supply chains
domestically to do that number one and
number two everything would get way more
expensive so when the san antonio troll
says i was against biden doing domestic
energy but i don't remember biden even
talking about that i was talking about
manufacturing domestically not gas not
gas so again troll criticize someone who
said it it wasn't me we don't have a
bottomless bank account like you do
another elites where you could just
catch an uber ride everywhere you go
so we feel it at the pump and we are
i've been i've been
all over the gas price thing and i've
been saying this is not 15 cents per
gallon we're talking about impactful
amounts of money now so i don't know
this guy must have me confused with
someone else maybe alex jones was saying
this stuff i don't know the majority
voted this is why
he's biden has to do this or he's
definitely going to lose
and i you just don't see that you see oh
we need to be
complete green energy because you drive
a car that you know not all of us could
afford that dude you have to
see it from the poor man's perspective i
i genuinely don't know what he's talking
about i did
i i haven't i don't know what commentary
of mine this is even a reference to not
even the poor man just a working class
and it's something i think you have
lived in this you know
wealthy liberal you know wealthy
neoliberal bubble for so long oh give me
a break dude yeah go go talk to someone
who said this stuff so there's a san
antonio troll um i i am still holding
out hope that someday someday i believe
it will happen
the san antonio troll will call
and actually address something i've said
as opposed to something he attributes to
me that i've never actually talked about
a florida senator rick scott's tax plan
is under fire and it should be and we're
going to talk about it on today's bonus
show
a few months ago couple months ago i
told you about the first successful
pig heart transplant into a human
sadly
the recipient an american man has died
and we're going to talk about
what this means for this particular
medical technology
what happened it is sad but we're going
to follow up on the story and the final
remaining american mask mandate is in
hawaii and that will be lifted in 16
days on march 26th we will talk about
now with state mandates
all going away
which municipalities are maintaining
masking requirements if any
and we'll talk about masks all of those
story or as marjorie taylor green likes
to say we will talk about mask on the
bonus show all of those stories and more
i will be joined by producer pat on the
bonus show you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
it is a great place to sign up i believe
the normal membership prices are perfect
but
you can get a discount using the coupon
code wow 22. now just remember
you will be
adversarial to alex jones if you sign up
as a member alex jones doesn't like the
bonus show oh the bonus show or you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad he's
against it
i am very much for the bonus though sign
up at joinpackman.com i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman